hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
you know today is today is April 1st
2013 which means of course you guys know
it is April Fool's Day
that being said try not to at least for
the next 24 hours try not to take
anything you see on the Internet sort of
headlines or product announcements too
seriously but that being said the
Internet's usually a pretty fun place on
April Fool's Day so without any further
ado we're going to go ahead and count
down the top five companies that have
been doing a pretty awesome job with
their April Fools pranks for the last
couple of years a lot of these are
internet-based companies but they're all
tech related companies so uh let me
further ado let's go ahead and check
those out
starting with five number five is reddit
on April 1st 2010 reddit made everyone
on the site and administrator which
means everyone had the ability to edit
post titles to upload things as much as
they want and to ban users which of
course sent the entire site into deep
and utter chaos but I think for April
Fool's Day that was actually a pretty
hilarious idea but even more fun on
April 1st 2011 instead of being able to
gift other users reddit gold you could
only gift other users reddit mold
now what reddit mold did if you were
gifted reddit mold it would slowly one
by one take away the amount of
characters you had to comment on at post
so you were unable to at first use the
letter e and then the letter B and then
the letter F and as you got more and
more reddit mold gifted to you you would
be slowly reduced until the last three
letters you had or MP and H to leave all
your comments on reddit and hilarity
ensued number four is actually Toshiba
now they haven't been all that great in
the past but one of the most recent ones
in fact last year in 2012 was pretty
hilarious and they basically put out
this video saying hey you know what
Apple is dominating the tablet game and
we know that we recognize that but you
know what all tablets out there are
pretty much the same everyone is using
rectangles every tablet is a rectangle
so they put out this really dedicated
spoof video introducing three new
tablets a circular tablet a heart shaped
tablet and a rhombus I think my favorite
was definitely the rhombus the rhombus
shaped tablet
out of all the shapes they could have
picked to introduce as a comedic sketch
that one was pretty funny so Toshiba
gets props at number four for their
awkward shaped tablet number three is
YouTube you probably saw this one coming
but every year on April Fool's Day
YouTube has some of the geekiest April
Fool's Day pranks so for example in 2011
YouTube on every single video put a 1911
button to celebrate their 100th
anniversary not really but they put a
1911 button on every video where if you
clicked it it would add is sort of a
yellowish and graininess to give every
video on YouTube and antique look and it
worked for every single video which
actually takes a lot more effort than
you might think in 2010 it was even more
geeky below the 1080p button below the
720p button below the 480p button and
below the 240 P button there was a text
P button which would display every video
on YouTube if you clicked it in a SC IR
art a si art which is actually a really
difficult feat to accomplish but they
said they had a whole page dedicated to
how it increases the literacy of YouTube
users but it was hilarious and yeah it
was actually really technically
complicated to pull off but it worked
and every single video could be played
as moving text on the screen this year
on YouTube the prank isn't quite as
geeky for April Fool's Day but it is
still pretty funny they're going to be
shutting down YouTube and for the next
10 years picking a video that wins a
video that wins all of YouTube it's
pretty hilarious you should watch the
video down below I'll have all the
pranks down below the like button on
this video that I'm referring to during
the course of this video so you can
check them out and relive them they're
all below and they're pretty funny so
check them all out number two is adblock
a lot of people on the web use an ad
blocker especially adblock adblock plus
is one of the most popular things on the
web so they tend to have a lot of power
on the web because a lot of people rely
on their service for a streamlined
smooth clean internet with no ads that
being said on April 1st last year
they're replaced every ad that would
have been blocked on the internet with a
picture of a cat that's what they did
and that was probably the best thing
they could have ever done because the
internet needs more cats well done and
number one you probably saw this one
coming also it is got a long history of
April Fool's Day pranks on the intern
Google they're basically the masters of
this stuff Google's April Fool's Day
hoaxes go as far back as the year 2000
where they introduced a new product
called mental plex which convinced users
to stare at a spiraling circle in the
middle of your screen and think of what
they wanted to Google search which was
sort of the beginning of a tradition of
a lot of geeky and well done and well
produced and funny and hilarious April
Fool's Day pranks in the past few years
Google's April Fool's Day stuff has
gotten more and more dedicated and
hilarious and well produced in 2008 they
launched 14 hoaxes one of which was
called Gmail time which allowed you to
timestamp your emails whenever you
wanted to basically in the future or the
past or whenever you want in 2010 Google
changed their name to Topeka in honor of
the city that also temporarily changed
their name to Google in 2011 there was
the legendary Gmail motion which allowed
users to supposedly compose their emails
by flailing their body pots around
moving around and basically using a body
language form of sign language to create
the emails that you want to send that
was probably the best thing Google's
done a long time it was funny the video
was funny the concept was funny it was
hilarious and it was a really well done
video to send a message lick a stamp and
place it down Google is always doing
something neat for April Fool's Day this
year so far what I've seen is Google
knows which is going to allow you to
smell what you want to search if you
search for a lemon you get to click the
send button and smell your monitor and
smell lemons and they also introduced a
new product called Google treasure map
so if you go to Google Maps today it's
going to look a lot like a treasure map
and it's an old style and I don't think
there's actually treasure on it but I
bet someone's going to find some Easter
Egg where you actually find some sort of
neat stuff in there so go ahead and
check it out like I said all the links
are down below either way thank you for
watching this quick video and hey enjoy
the Internet today guys today is a
pretty good day to just not take things
seriously and laugh at some headlines
that you'd usually only see in the onion
either way if you see anything else
that's awesome definitely leave it in a
comment section below I'll be updating
the description below the like button
with all the new things that we find
together over the course of these next
24 hours so it'll be sort of an archive
of the best internet hoaxes that
happened today
either way like I said thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next video
you